[Musica]
quando non sento l'affetto che cerco la
comprensione e la condivisione
io urlo il mio barbarico yacht che
risuona sopra i tetti del mondo sono i
versi di una poesia di walt whitman
ve lo ricordate il film l'attimo
fuggente quando il professore robbie
williams cerca di spronare uno dei
ragazzi il più timido a tirare fuori la
voce gli chiede di fare il suo barbarico
yacht lo chiama ululato perché urlare
deriva proprio da ululare e lo incalzano
stuzzica finché alla fine il ragazzo
dopo aver fatto il suo urlo il suo
ululato si sente pronto per donare una
parte di sé agli altri per tirare fuori
il suo racconto più intimo quella voce
che altrimenti avrebbe tenuto per sé e
mette i suoi compagni nella condizione
di ascoltarlo
la voce è quanto di più fisico esista la
voce è uno strumento potentissimo e con
la voce che ci mettiamo in relazione con
l'altro che ci scambiamo informazioni e
con la voce che argomentiamo e
sosteniamo il nostro pensiero
il nostro punto di vista la voce la
prima cosa che un neonato riconosce
della madre
anche perché la voce della madre lo
abbraccia fin da quando è nel grembo
filtrata dal liquido amniotico e siamo
stati tutti abbracciati da quel liquido
che ci parlava e attraverso la voce
della madre
abbiamo imparato a conoscere chi ci
aspettava da fuori ea conoscere anche
chi eravamo noi
e va da sé che la prima cosa che abbiamo
fatto appena nati e stata di far sentire
la nostra di voce con un urla un grido
un gemito per dire ehi ci sono sono viva
è stato il nostro primo barbarico yacht
in qualche modo
in principio era il verbo dicono le
sacre scrive
e se ci pensiamo bene anche il big bang
è stata una specie di grandissimo urlo
il più potente di sempre è un urlo
decisamente costruttivo ho visto quello
che ha prodotto
oggi vorrei parlare di questo di urli
costruttivi e utilizzo volutamente il
plurale urli al posto di urla perché
vorrei che ogni volta che nomino la
parola voi vi immaginiate l'urlo nella
sua accezione più animale io sono sempre
stata una che parla tanto ma che urla
poco e sono anni che lavoro sull'urlo
perché mi affascina l'idea che lì dentro
si annidi tutta la potenzialità di una
persona qualche anno fa durante la
presentazione di un mio libro sul lago
di lecco
ho provato sulla mia pelle i brividi di
un urlo corale di gioia sì ho fatto
urlare tutti come in una specie di rito
collettivo è stato meraviglioso
nel 2017 l'ho proposto alle donne di una
multinazionale inglese per celebrare i
cent'anni della conquista del diritto al
voto si sono dati un appuntamento allo
stesso giorno alla stessa ora nelle
varie sedi del mondo e si sono fatte un
video mentre urlavano di gioia
esperimenti e perché li ho fatti non lo
so forse perché come dice emil cioran se
fossi costretta a rinunciare al mio
dilettantismo e nell'urlo che vorrei
specializzarmi e poi l'urlo e
trasversali non conosce discriminazioni
da un urlo non puoi sapere di che
nazionalità io si sa di quale sia il
colore della mia pelle di quale
religione quale orientamento sessuale
come io conto in banca
l'urlo e la forma primordiale di
comunicazione è il nostro verso prima
che col tempo si faccia parola
eppure non è così automatico trovare la
forza di urlare in modo costruttivo
perché l'urlo è un punto di approdo ma è
anche un punto di partenza
urla l'atleta che arriva al traguardo e
urla l'attore prima di salire sul palco
urla una donna che mette al mondo un
figlio e urlano le donne e gli uomini
che si battono per far valere i propri
diritti
nello sport è abbastanza usuale vedere
gli atleti che urlano per darsi forza in
vista di una sfida gli all blacks per
esempio i giocatori di rugby più famosi
al mondo
prima della partita quando fanno la caa
quella danza fatta di gesti e di parole
urlate in faccia all'avversario
probabilmente hanno già vinto lì 50 per
cento della partita e questo vale sia
per la nazionale femminile che per la
nazionale maschile perché nello sport
non c'è distinzione di genere se si deve
urlare ma proviamo immaginarci per un
attimo fuori dal campo anche se loro non
conosce discriminazioni è pur vero che
col tempo si è caricato di significati
di genere ben precisi proviamo ad
immaginarci un uomo che urla no
avrete pensato a tarzan al di là di
tarzan quindi fuori dal campo di gioco
ma anche fuori dalla giungla
proviamo ad immaginarci un uomo
nell'atto di urlare la prima cosa che
viene in mente è il potere il comando
oppure la rabbia l'aggressività un uomo
che urla tendenzialmente fa paura incute
timore proviamo ora a immaginarci una
donna e di collegarle l'azione dell'urlo
viene abbastanza automatico pensare al
dolore e alla violenza subita
troppo se ne parla e ha ragione ahimè
certo qualcuno avrà avuto l'immagine più
leggera della mamma della zia della
sorella dell'amica assi mia madre quando
fa l'isterica che urla
oppure una via mica una pazza totale che
urla continuamente ecco l'urlo collegato
ad una donna se non è dolore e isteria o
follia ed è così da millenni conoscete
il mito greco di filomela filomena è la
sorella di prof nel moglie del re di
tracia il re ama lei senza essere
corrisposto e un giorno di fronte
all'ennesimo rifiuto della cognata il re
la violenta e per impedirle di
raccontare l'accaduto
le taglie la lingua ma filomela e
furbissima e trova comunque il modo di
raccontare di farsi sentire la sua voce
diventa la sua mano che ricama una tela
dove descrive tutto quello che ha subito
quante volte alle donne
succede di sentire quella mutilazione
senza trovare l'espediente di filomela
per raccontarsi per dire per parlare e
non lo fanno per per pudore per paura
per educazione sipre ducazione perché le
donne vengono educate a non alzare
troppo la voce a non dire sempre tutto
quello che pensano pena gli appellativi
di isterica o pazza di cui sopra
nel medioevo le donne che urlavano la
loro diversità il loro dissenso le
bruciavano
in tempi più recenti le rinchiudevano
dei manicomi
in realtà in quella voce sopra le righe
rispetto alle altre c'era solo la voglia
di dire al mondo che a loro la lingua
non gliel'aveva tagliata nessuno eppure
il modo di zittire l'hanno trovato
comunque e per una filomela che trova il
modo di ricamare la propria storia ce ne
sono migliaia che rimangono in silenzio
per fortuna la storia ci ha donato anche
donne che sapendo di non essere
ascoltate hanno escogitato un piccolo
espediente hanno affidato ad un gesto il
proprio racconto
pensate ad artemisia gentileschi e al
suo giuditta e oloferne
guardate l'espressione di giuditta nel
decapitare oloferne che ci racconta
della ferita che la pittrice ha subito
con lo stupro si potrebbe dire una
pittura urlata pensate a rosa parks che
ha urlato il suo basta alla
discriminazione
semplicemente non alzandosi quel giorno
su quell'autobus pensate storia di oggi
una ragazzina con un impermeabile giallo
che tutti venerdì non va a scuola ma si
presenta davanti al parlamento svedese
con un cartello che dice sciopero per il
clima
tutte voci che hanno trovato il modo di
farsi ascoltare perché ci sono gesti che
valgono quanto un grido certo il potere
della voce sta anche nel sapere quando
non utilizzarla in sottrazione
pensate al silenzio di gandhi e la
nonviolenza gesti che ancora risuonano
in un periodo storico in cui tutti
urlano per nascondere la pochezza dei
contenuti seri dessimo all'urlo la sua
dignità e la sua fisicità nella sua
valenza più positiva cosa potrebbe
succedere
ce lo siamo chieste durante una cena io
e quattro amiche
ne abbiamo parlato molto e alla fine
abbiamo deciso di far nascere
un'associazione un'associazione per
costruire una urlo teca si un urlo teca
che possa riunire tutti gli urli
costruttivi di cui l'umanità è capace e
durante quella cena ho sentito che
quanto mi aveva detto anni fa una
psicologa doveva diventare realtà
mi disse la nostra cultura è il
cristianesimo per quanto uno possa
essere osservante o meno dobbiamo vedere
quella storia anche da un altro punto di
vista
se vogliamo capirne il messaggio
maria è una donna che riceve dallo
spirito santo il dono di un figlio è
perché si compia la volontà di dio non
dovrà sacrificare al mondo
sinteticamente spiegazione
maria è la forza creatrice che è
femminile in qualunque persona essa
risiede lo spirito santo e l'intuizione
che general idea ma perché questa idea
possa farsi progetto possa realizzarsi
va sacrificata va condivisa
nessuna idea se non si dona agli altri
può diventare realtà se non ne parli non
esiste
e così durante quella cena è avvenuto il
mio piccolo miracolo per una volta non
mi sono accontentata di aver avuto solo
l'idea ma l'ho condivisa ho tirato fuori
la mia voce la mia voce vi costruttiva
perché tutti abbiamo una voce e dovremmo
essere consapevoli che attraverso quella
voce possiamo intervenire sul mondo
modificandolo e arricchendolo senz'altro
facciamoci dono l'un l'altro di quella
voce e anche se sentiamo gli effetti
della mutilazione culturale il ricordo
di phenom e l'ha visto che a noi la
lingua non ce l'ha tagliata nessuno
cerchiamo di farla uscire cerchiamo di
aiutare le persone che hanno più
difficoltà a raccontarsi a a parlare a
dire quello che stanno facendo quello
che pensano quello che vogliono a
raccontarsi davvero per una volta nei
propri successi
sì ce l'ho fatta sì ce la farò sì ce la
sto facendo
coco chanel diceva che l'atto più
coraggioso rimane quello di pensare a se
stessi ad alta voce
e allora siamo coraggiosi siamo audaci e
brillanti bolden brilliant facciamoci
dono l'un l'altro di quella voce perché
tutti abbiamo una storia da urlo da
raccontare
e l'urlo teca ne vuole riunire tutte
queste voci tutti questi progetti perché
la voce è il progetto ognuno con la
propria tonalità sia ben inteso non
abbiamo tutti lo stesso tono di voce non
abbiamo tutti la stessa grinta non
abbiamo tutti lo stesso progetto ma
abbiamo tutti la voce
e se è vero che il suono modifica la
materia
ci deve essere un modo per dare una
nuova sterzata a questo universo
combattendo le urla di disperazione che
sono veramente tante citiamo li quegli
urli costrutti quegli urli distruttivi
infiliamoci nelle loro frequenze nelle
loro vibrazioni tossiche
combattiamo lì sullo stesso piano diamo
la via un nuovo big bang non sarà una
cosa semplice e tanto meno immediata ma
dobbiamo cercare di farli tremare quei
tetti sopra i quali fa risuonare il
nostro barbarico yacht per chi non sente
l'affetto che cerca la comprensione e la
condivisione come diceva walt whitman si
sa mai che qualcosa cambi perché
vogliamo che qualcosa cambi no siamo
tutti d'accordo su questo
in realtà se ci fossero degli scettici
adesso spero di convertirli in qualche
modo perché vorrei fare con voi un gioco
per farvi sentire sulla vostra pelle
quanto è potente l'urlo corale
costruttivo e aggiungere un piccolo
mattoncino anche all'urlo teca che ne ha
bisogno ovviamente avete trovato sulle
vostre sedute delle borse all'interno
delle quali ci sono dei sacchetti di
carta semplici sacchetti di carta come
quelli del pane prendetelo e apritelo e
adesso vi chiedo di pensare tutti a un
progetto che volete realizzare o che
avete già realizzato a un traguardo già
raggiunto o da raggiungere qualcosa di
totalmente propositivo e costruttivo
guardatevi anche tra di voi pensate che
nella testa del vostro compagno adesso
c'è qualcosa di totalmente costruttivo
un pensiero positivo e poi magari nel
coffee break e gli chiedete qual era il
suo progetto e chissà che non avvenga
anche il vostro piccolo miracolo in
questa condivisione
al mio tre
vi chiedo di urlare con tutta la grinta
che avete e che volete mettere dentro
questo progetto se vi volete alzare in
piedi
ce l'avete tutti il progetto 123
[Applauso]
richiudete e ve lo mettete in borsa e
sarà custodito qui dentro e quando
risentire del bisogno do riaprite e lo
ascoltate e vi torneranno i brividi e
fatele altri di urli sempre più
costruttivi dai che lo facciamo girare
per il verso giusto questo mondo
[Applauso]
[Musica]